bali villas are beautiful but this one
has a few problems
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
today we're going to be looking at and
reacting to the house tour
from do you travel also known as jack
morris's
brand new barley villa now i say brand
new this video is about nine months old
and full disclosure
i did view this video when it came out
but i wanted to react to this house in
particular
because well one it is a truly beautiful
house so
don't get my comments wrong in this
video but i do find
some faults in it and something that i
think people need to actually be aware
of
when they look at houses now i'm going
to put one of my headphones in so
that you guys don't have to listen to
the music twice and i can actually edit
this video properly
but let's begin with some actually
amazing
straight away in that first 20 seconds
mainly the
20 to 23 second footage is where i
really want to start with this
there's some serious safety issues but
being bali it's
a very very different culture over there
and they have different regulations
in australia there is no way you would
get away with some scaffolding that's
built out of bamboo
and kind of just hanging off the side of
the building but that's okay let's
continue with this one
[Music]
just there at about 45 seconds is when
you see the couple on top of the roof
with nobel australia they can literally
jump off
almost six seven meters from the top of
that roof with no safety whatsoever
so again by not having that balustrade
there and if you don't know what a
balustrade is it's basically just either
a glass fence or a rail or something to
protect you from falling over
is a pretty big safety hazard and
something to be concerned about
there's definitely some more elements
that i want to talk about a bit later on
from those planters and the climate
conditions of bali in particular
but let's keep going through this video
but so far there's a couple
fundamental things that as beautiful as
this villa is you couldn't build it here
in australia unfortunately
after renting villas here for two years
we decided to finally buy a place but
just couldn't find a house we loved
that's when we came up with the idea of
building we met up with a contractor who
had just secured a piece of land and
with only one week
we signed contracts and started to build
so here they say that they
basically signed a contract to start
build straight away within one week
so that means it wasn't an architecture
designed house it was something off the
plan
but for something off the plan that's
actually really really nice i think
there aren't too many houses here in
australia that you can buy off the plan
that are this beautiful and this unique
so that element in itself
is really really amazing for such a
country like bali
so the main area as you're walking to
the front door is actually really really
nice
the sunken lounge that overlooks the
whole backyard the big glass windows
the exposed concrete ceiling the fans
the rustic industrial look
it all ties in really really well so
from an interior design point of view
and from an architectural sense
and considering the simple fact this is
a off-the-plan home it's actually
really well done i love the fact that
when you get to their kitchen you have
this
double void that lets in all that
natural light from the rear side of the
building
it makes that kitchen so grand and so
vast and with a staircase wrapping up
behind it and around it
with the little almost sky bridge to the
side it's
genuinely a really nice space to
entertain and i think that that element
there
for my opinion kitchens are usually the
heart of the home it's where people
spend a lot of time
entertaining when friends and family
come over and then they migrate outside
so i think the big island bench with
lots of space to sit
the large windows overlooking the
draping
vegetation out the side is again really
really pretty and
done very well so because we built so
many big windows around the sunken
seating area
we didn't really have any space for a tv
so instead we put a projector up here on
this projector idea and dropping it down
from the ceiling is actually
really really clever a lot of my clients
in particular ask for large windows
grand vistas to overlook whatever
beautiful space they have
when you usually come to an architect or
an architectural designer or anybody in
the industry
you want to have the best of everything
you can so being able to offer a simple
solution like this
where the projector drops down from the
ceiling potentially some automatic
blinds come and close
it's all synced in with a google home
smart system or something
that the user can actually interact with
makes
a home truly a home and makes it that
one step better from your normal kit
home
so even though again i'm going back to
the fact that this is a custom home
straight off the plan it has actually
been thought out really really well and
i think
um jack morris here and his girlfriend
or partner i'm not actually sure i don't
follow them too much
have done an amazing job at decorating
this space and making it truly unique
for their
purposes now their master bedroom is
actually really well thought out and
really beautiful
but again unfortunately there's some
regulations here that wouldn't actually
allow you to create this space in
australia
the fact that they have a sliding door
from their bedroom directly
into the pool is
well amazing first of all but
unfortunately in australia you can't do
that
your pools need to be completely
screened off so that people can't
accidentally fall into them
having your pool literally one step from
your bedroom is
most people's dream and desire but there
isn't actually a way that you can do
this on a simple budget in australia you
can't just put a sliding door
and jump straight to your pool i do love
how they've actually done
their rear wall the feature wall with
timber cladding
and actually hidden their walk-in robot
behind
so it's a secret doors to the walk-in
robe and that nobody knows where it is
it's a little bit visible given but at
the end of the day it's something
different
something unique and it is definitely
something thought out so again
even though these guys have gone out and
gotten a basic home from
a builder randomly in bali they've done
a really really good job of thinking
through the details
i'm not sure what they were given as a
package but here in australia for
example you're just given some
plasterboard walls
and a bit of paint sometimes if you're
lucky so these guys have gone over and
above
to actually get all the details right
and truly create a space
that may not be architecturally designed
but it seems as if it has been
really really thought out so their
backyard is really really nice again
and i do love it but what i wanted to
point out previously when i was talking
about
the exterior and at the intro with those
draping plants on the side
being barley and being such a hot
humid climate those draping plants are
actually going to cause some structural
damage to their house over the long term
having continuous moisture on the side
of what appears to be
potentially concrete potentially not is
going to cause some serious cracking in
the future
so i don't think they would have
actually thought this one through
even though it does look amazing i don't
see any sort
of waterproofing any sort of drainage
anything like that it just seems like a
very simple planter box that they've
gone in dumped some plants and made this
space
so in the next five years it'd be
actually really interesting to go back
and view this house again
to see what kind of structural impact
these planters have had around the house
so there's way too much talking in this
video first of all and they don't really
show too much it's a bit hard to
understand the space that first
cinematic intro clip that we saw was
really really good i wish they did some
more of that
to actually get a grand understanding of
what this space is
but the balcony and the rooftop is a
beautiful space it is something that
a lot of people truly wish that they
want
um looking at this it's kind of hard to
understand if they have any falls and
drainage but
at maybe 19 minutes 50 seconds there
seems to be some sort of
channel drain towards the edge of the
balcony so that could actually be a good
drainage system
but in a heavy downpour i'd be really
curious to see how that rooftop
actually managed the water as we all
know water doesn't flow anywhere if it's
a flat surface
so i'm hoping there's some sort of fall
on these tiles that drains this water
away really really well
otherwise that's going to be a bit of a
problem later down the track
with all that heavy water sitting on top
of the house i think you can imagine
what's going to happen
but from a general sense of looking at
this building i would assume that they
have
interpreted this and they've done a
really good job of this balcony
again unfortunately you'd have to have
some balustrading across the
perimeter of that balcony to stop people
from falling over in australia you could
definitely have it
on the inside of the rooftop so it
wouldn't look as bad from the ground and
it could be all glass that would be
almost seamless
but that is a very very large trip
hazard fall hazard
where a little kid could run across fall
somebody could get pushed all sorts of
things could happen on top of that
rooftop
again beautiful space really wish it
could be possible but
in australia obviously those regulations
would never allow you to build something
like this
on your rooftop you can definitely have
a rooftop depending on the council and
things like that
um the concrete slab would cost you a
lot of money to be able to have a flat
concrete slab exposed like that
lots of downpipe lots of drainage i
would have loved to see more floor waste
in this rooftop
to actually be able to be really
confident that this roof
wouldn't have any water leaks any
problems down track
i don't really see too many in this
image here but they don't really
showcase that whole rooftop
so it's a bit unfortunate but again
you'd hope that they've been designed
really well
overall amazing amazing space now before
we sign off on this video
i want to go to jack's uh actual
instagram page where he goes through the
construction of this building because
this is this is the most concerning part
as somebody here in australia
that would be horrified to see this on a
construction site
um again barely different rules
different regulations
but just seeing what has gone on there
how the guys walk around
is very very concerning um but yeah
let's quickly go through the videos on
uh jack's story
yeah so here's the clip it's literally
just the one tradie
going down the spine of these stairs no
balustrading
no supports no anything no hard hat he's
in thongs
um there's no boots no nothing like
it's concerning to see people on a job
site like this there's so many injuries
that could happen
it definitely wouldn't fly in australia
but it's just incredible to see
just the general construction process
bamboo everywhere
very very different to how things
construct in australia obviously but
that's not even here or there that's how
they construct things
you can definitely see some differences
in the construction methods and
when things go into the actual project
like that bath framing before any tiles
are there
um a completed bath in the bathroom
that's concrete and is
very detailed the pools
i don't know how yeah that's don't have
much on that
but yeah again he's walking up the
stairs in his thongs
on a commercial construction site so
highly dangerous definitely would not
recommend doing anything like that
okay so they do have some scaffolding up
now
when the balustrade has come onto the
stairs
they've actually put on when he's
talking about
the nice stone kitchen bench it's
actually quite nice very thick slab so
that would have been extremely expensive
balustrading's come into the stairs
temporary
looks like just timber balustrading
yeah overall they seem to take their
time and the finishes
clean up after themselves but you can
see just with the water
basically sitting on that concrete
there's no falls indicated there's
they haven't really thought about it i'd
also be very concerned about
the slip resistance on these tiles next
to the pool
i mean i've been to bali many times so
they're not exactly the most
safe pools to run around but again two
fully grown adults so
i'm sure they'll be a lot safer than
that it's amazing to see how much those
vines have grown over the edge of that
building though
i think this was 82 weeks ago nine
months ago the original video so it's
about a year
and those vines have yeah they've boomed
they've grown over those whole
um facade there so that's that's amazing
how quickly plants grow over there in
indonesia
let me let me pause it on this this
video here this bloke
this bloke is barefooted on a
construction site
there is exposed concrete on the floor
i'm guessing nail is exposed wires
it's just no concern for safety i mean
that's just scary looking at it from my
point of view
but again yeah very very very different
construction over there versus here
that's just that's crazy anyway grand
scheme of things
absolutely beautiful beautiful house
some things that i would be concerned
about
if i were to design their home mainly
for the fact that
you don't want to go and invest i think
he said somewhere about a million
dollars in some of the documentation i
read
into your pride and joy and then have
some serious
serious structural concerns later down
the track you don't want this building
deteriorating
if you've ever been to bali before
you'll know that the buildings over
there don't last very long they
deteriorate very very quickly
a new hotel one year may be beautiful
but three years down the track it's
already deteriorated
so in my prediction i'd expect something
similar to happen to a house like
this unless it's extremely well
maintained which for their sake i am
hoping they maintain it very well
anyway big shout out to both of these
two for creating this beautiful home
it is an incredible house which i'm sure
they will live many beautiful years in
and have some amazing experiences they
definitely deserve it they've worked
very hard over the past decade basically
since instagram started
they are truly inspirations in the
travel community but again i just wanted
to review their house from an
australian's point of view
and the differences between our
construction and their construction
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that like
button to help this video with the
youtube algorithm
smash that subscribe button to subscribe
to the channel to see more content like
this
and as always i will see you next monday